as you know I encourage viewers to call
it and leave us voicemails but I never
have time to listen to them our crew at
the opposition has put some voice mails
together that I have honestly never
heard before but I promise to answer any
questions and vomit my thoughts straight
at you
I've citizen journalist Tim Balz joining
me to add his expertise
I can't wait to tear these people new
assholes George writes at welcome I
think these are mostly fans of the show
so oh yeah I mean in a helpful way right
well I'm excited to hear what you have
to say Chuck let's fire up the first
call hi Jordan this is Diane from
Chester land and I want to know why are
all the actors in Hollywood liberal I
mean I feel like they're just democratic
pawns I get the feeling they're being
told what to say where to stand how to
look it's disgusting and I mean the
whole place it's a liberal infestation
Hollywood why not Halle Cole they say
conservatives can't do comedy right hey
that was she made a really really great
point though all right and and it gets
to something that we have talked about
on this show is that Hollywood is
scripted it's almost like they have
people writing lines and then they read
the lines and then they say the lines
here's a funny that there's an area in
New York that you can go to they call it
Soho it stands for north of Houston okay
and and what I've seen it is these these
libs sell what they call screenplays and
their actual scripts of the words that
are being said in movies and famous
movies almost famous
The Godfather The Godfather Part three
and if you flip through it it's the
exact words that these so called actors
these these human beings these liberals
with their own points of view it's the
same words that they say on screen hold
on flip through it are you saying that
it's on paper when they could put it on
an iPad and not waste paper thank you
see this is where they're hypocritical
Jordan this is where they're
hypocritical yeah yeah they want us to
cut up our little six-packs of plastic
so that that birds in the ocean don't
eat it and die when birds live in the
sky and fish live in the ocean it's it's
it's so easy to pull this but you pull
one string and the whole ball of
spaghetti becomes unravel
totally is unbelievable well let's see
our next call hi Jordan
I got a bit of a problem I hate Justin
Trudeau and all of his liberal
long-haired ideas but I also recognize
that he is a handsome man yeah sure what
to do about that because oh I hate him
so much I wanna kiss him this is the
category I call oops he's hot you had a
Obama fit in this category for just a
second right which yeah oh yeah when
Obama was on the campaign trail I was
oops he's hot and then the second he put
his hand on the Bible and got sworn in I
was like something's not right we need
to take him down
what do you see a man shirtless kites
ayleid and you're gonna have it
instinctive response my response was
he's hot yeah that's the evil response
people can have it oopsies hot reaction
that doesn't mean that you're gonna
support them that doesn't mean that
you're gonna vote for them that means
that you will eventually probably go
into a side room turn off all of the
lights and try to repress the feelings
that you have build that into a ball of
anger and then aim that anger at that
person that you cared about just hours
earlier it's normal but seriously shout
out to shout out to you because the
first time I met you I thought oops he's
hot and to be honest there are times
when Jordan still does things and I
think oops he's hot
so it endures
[Applause]
are you gonna good other call Chuck
Jordan this is Grace from Northampton
mass love I run a mixed martial arts
studio for women and their dogs and we
have this argument all the time which
founding father would win in a cage
match melee fight I love your show love
you man love grace it's a great question
I think I obviously people gonna go with
Abraham Lincoln he's gangly he's large
he has a top hat he knows to at least be
on the receiving end of a gun and so uh
know your point is fair violence begets
violence
exactly yeah that's why I like yeah you
know if you punish a kid with violence
they're gonna get tougher yep Andrew
Jackson is a clear one Andrew Johnson
also a tough scrappy guy yeah Martin Van
Buren I like him a lot he he is somebody
doesn't get enough credit I know I know
pneumonia took that man down William
Henry Harrison was that what I say said
Martin Van Buren correct I am correcting
you but I have to do it for the sanctity
of this show Martin Van Buren was the
eighth president who came after Andrew
Jackson was the ninth president why do
Barry Harris why are you doing this rain
notes in because I have to set the
record we have to stand atop a
foundation wheel every wheel we also
create our own records do it what we do
is we have our own their anger toward
the libs and knowing that the globalists
are trying to are trying to take us out
with them so we have integrity this
honesty anger toward the live history is
good by the way list agenda that we hate
history is those are our four founding
pillars history is written by the way
like the four presidents that we have
named this room Jackson the seventh
President Martin Van Buren who counts us
too because he's got a long name as a
president and then William Henry
Harrison who counts while he probably
counts as more than two guys because
he's got even longer name the martin van
buren I'm gonna stop talking because I'm
leaking secrets about the show
what then William Henry Harrison died
after because after 9/11 is are we going
to say there are some people that say I
know there are that his pneumonia was a
way to get him out of office by the Whig
party and then they put him on ice and
then they're gonna resurrect him at any
point to become the true successor to
the American crown I know it residency
go to Tim's blog he has a lot of this
laid out for us yeah that's true that's
all the time we have today but if you at
home have any questions give us a call
at one eight three three opposing and
leave a voice mail with your name and
where you're from and we might use it on
the show and if you'd rather email too
bad
I was recently hacked and now I'm being
cyber bullied by a neighborhood teen so
I had to go off the grid